what's going on guys this is rob and
today on our beyond omega level series
we're going to cover a character that i
cannot believe i have not covered yet in
this series but as i was going through
my videos to see who i did cover he was
noticeably absent and of course i'm
referring to the devourer of world's
galactus himself or g-dog as i like to
call him seriously somehow we've covered
galactus daughter but galactus himself i
don't know but that'll be fixed today so
galactus was created by stan lee and
jack kirby and made his first appearance
in fantastic four number 48 in 1966. now
on why he created galactus stan lee said
that he was simply the latest in a long
line of villains they were creating in
the fantastic four title and that he and
kirby wanted to basically outdo
themselves so they figured the only way
to do that was to create a character
that was nearly god-like in terms of
power but to put a different spin on the
character they wanted to make a villain
that was not necessarily evil but that
consumed planets because he simply needs
their energy for nourishment in order to
survive now getting into his comic book
origin in the universe that existed
before the current marvel universe there
was an explorer named gallon of the
planet tah and as that universe ends
gallon gathers a crew and journeys to
the point of impending destruction of
the universe itself in an attempt to
save his people now everybody aboard the
ship dies except for gala so he
basically led them to their own doom who
of course encounters an entity called
the sentience of the universe which was
basically the totality of all life in
all of the universe an abstract similar
to eternity in the main marvel universe
but marvel never really bothers to
explain the difference between the two
but the sentience and gallon basically
merge and become part of the cosmic egg
that would be the beginning of the
current universe now after just stating
for billions of years galactus
spacecraft is discovered by one of the
watchers and even though he sensed
galactus enormous potential for
destruction the watcher chooses not to
destroy him knowing that he would be
necessary for preserving order in the
universe now galactus remains in a
spacecraft for billions of years
following his discovery by the watcher
and when he awakens he almost
immediately consumes the planet
archeopia which would become the first
in a long line of worlds that would fall
victim to the devourer now after
consuming the planet galactus then began
constructing his new home a world ship
large enough to be orbited by planets
which he named tatu after his fallen
homeworld now feeling guilty for
destroying so many lives galactus
temporarily vowed to seek out only
uninhabited worlds to feed on but
eventually deems himself to be a
necessary force to the universe that's
too important to worry about something
as trivial and begins consuming
inhabited worlds as well now to aid him
in this task he employs heralds to seek
out worlds to devour imbuing each of
them with a fraction of his own immense
power known as the power cosmic now the
first of these was the fallen one who
proved to be so cruel and unpredictable
that galactus imprisoned him inside a
space prison called the kiln galactus's
next and probably best known herald
would not be employed for several
millennia later when galactus found his
way to the planet zen loft now to spare
his home world from being consumed by
galactus one of the citizens named noren
radd bargains with galactus to serve as
his herald in exchange for goliathus
sparing his planet now galactus agrees
and then gives norn rad the power cosmic
transforming him into the silver surfer
now the surfer travels through the
universe finding uninhabited worlds to
satiate galactus hunger but galactus
gradually alters the silver surfer's
mind so that he begins finding worlds
that were actually inhabited now when
the surfer leads galactus to earth he
encounters a fantastic four and the
thing's girlfriend alicia masters who
convinced the surfer to rebel against
galactus who basically leaves the earth
and vows never to consume it but
banishes the surfer there as punishment
for his rebellion and so after this
galactus would be a mainstay of the
marvel comics universe and would show up
several times as an antagonist of the
fantastic four and in various cosmic
stories almost always as a threat to
completely destroy whatever planet he
comes across however there was a period
of time recently when instead of
functioning as the devourer of worlds
galactus became the lifebringer when he
restored life to the planets that he'd
previously destroyed but he has since
returned to consuming worlds and has
taken thor as his latest in a long line
of heralds which ended relatively
recently so before we get into galactus
powers and feats i do want to address
exactly why he exists as it relates to
the cosmic order of the marvel universe
now as one of the oldest entities in the
universe having existed since the
universe was created galactus existence
is integral to preserving order in the
marvel universe he is said to serve as a
balance between the entities of death
and eternity who are two abstract
entities that have also existed since
the beginning of the universe itself and
together the three of them are said to
comprise the great triangle that is the
universe according to eternity if
galactus were to die the entire universe
itself would ultimately collapse now the
existence of galactus also prevents the
coming of abraxas the converse of
eternity and the embodiment of
destruction who we'll probably cover in
a future video so exactly what are
galactus powers well like i say so many
times on these beyond omega level videos
pretty much everything the best way we
can describe galactus is not omnipotent
meaning there's basically nothing he
can't do his vast powers are fueled by
the planets he consumes and he uses
devices called elemental converters to
change the matter he consumes into
energy in addition to being able to
absorb energy from other cosmic entities
now galactus is the source and primary
wielder of the power cosmic which allows
him to perform a variety of feats such
as matter manipulation energy projection
teleportation force field and portal
creation perform telepathy and
telekinesis on a universal scale and
even resurrect the dead and create life
we know the fact that he can destroy
planets and even solar systems as well
as recreate destroyed planets that
galactus is well beyond omega level but
i want to take a look at some of the
feats he's performed so we can get a
real sense of just how powerful this guy
is so when galactus went up against the
phoenix force he was able to absorb its
energy and had gene grey not interfered
he would have been able to kill the
phoenix which would have done
irreparable damage to the time stream
galactus has defeated mephisto in his
own realm where mephisto himself is
nearly omnipotent and the battle between
them wipes out countless planets and
ends when mephisto surrenders to avoid
galactus consuming his entire realm when
the annihilation wave invaded the marvel
universe galactus wiped it out with one
energy blast destroying three solar
systems in the process and emitting this
blast did not slow galactus down at all
now it needs to be pointed out that
prior to doing this galactus energy was
being siphoned off by thanos and
annihilus so he was extremely hungry and
therefore significantly weakened when he
did this basically galactus was hangry
and furthermore the reason annihilus was
using galactus was that he planned on
turning him into a bomb that would wipe
out the entire marvel universe and the
negative zone but when thanos figured
out what he was doing he freed galactus
so galactus could wipe out all of
nihilus forces something else that i
also want you guys to keep in mind here
the forces of annihilus during the
annihilation conquest storyline had
conquered about half of the universe if
not three quarters of it right literally
the story opens up with like richard
ryder nova and peter quill star-lord
fleeing for their lies running what is
in effect an evacuation team they call
it a unified front to face off against
the the threat of the annihilation wave
they weren't fighting anything they were
all just evacuating people and fleeing
for their lives and trying not to die
but galactus was able to cause a star to
explode and exists within the star
without being destroyed and it's said
that if he were to enter a black hole
the black hole itself would be destroyed
by the sheer amount of luminescent
energy that he produces galactus also
possesses one of the most powerful
weapons in the marvel universe the
ultimate nullifier which is described as
being much a part of galactus as his
heart and is capable of wiping out
entire universes and probably the most
significant moment in the history of
galactus happened relatively recently
when galactus traveled to the realm of
dormammu and consumed it and even
absorbed dormammu himself it was nuts so
yeah that is obviously not a complete
list of galactus feats by any means but
i think it gives you a pretty good idea
of how powerful this guy is here's one
of the things that's going to blow your
mind though as powerful as galactus is
one of the crazy things is franklin
richards is more powerful there's a
point in the story where galactus
basically fights these mad celestials
from an alternate universe right from
like an alternate reality and the
celestials all merge into like a giant
celestial being right a singular being
and they kill galactus so franklin
richards from the future comes to the
present and combines the power of his
younger self with his own power and then
sends the mad celestials to the other
side of the universe then like when the
mad celestials show back up he's like
it's all good man i got this y'all he
resurrects galactus from the dead makes
galactus his herald and then the two of
them fight the mad celestials and win it
was amazing oh my god jonathan hickman's
fantastic four was absolutely amazing it
was so ridiculously good so yeah
galactus is ridiculously overpowered in
marvel comics just insane how powerful
this guy is but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
about our beyond omega level video on
galactus and let me know if there's
anybody else you all want me to see yes
aaron wilder i have seen your requests
but we have to give other people a
chance otherwise we'll do nothing but
aaron wilder videos because this guy
posts requests like 15 characters at a
time anyway guys we're gonna bring this
to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace